dude we're both on the road right now
yeah we've just performed at t-pains
Wisconsin Fest Wisconsin Fest okay and
probably some people would be surprised
to know that you did music there not
comp well comedy music
the music yeah yeah music I mean some of
the songs have a funny right like
element but I'm not
I apologize for trying to stuff you into
comedy yeah but we did listen to it and
uh you know like the Judge Judy song is
hilarious thanks man that one
that one I was Judge Judy I put that out
and I'm like uh what was that song
that's really that song is only I only
made that song because my
I didn't like how much my mom liked
watching Judge Judy I didn't get it
it's addiction yeah because he was like
what it's not it's no
but I guess the the how predictable and
comfortable it is is part of
but that's what it was like it's like
she's just condescending the people over
small civil disputes over and over which
is fine to knock it out but you know
I appreciate the
the structure and the business but she's
also this other options there she is the
wealthiest television personality in the
history of the world yeah I believe I've
been what like more than Oprah for real
syndications I think uh I gotta believed
that the uh sampling Judge Judy's voice
is potentially more of an issue I don't
think you can sample her voice
she's in the track big time oh she's
gonna get her money
against Judge Judy
I just take that [ __ ] right down I don't
like the song
you're like sir she might be coming at
she retroactively yeah they're like I
performed this once live it doesn't even
work but on my show The Press of like
depressed
yeah maybe yeah I don't think I think
she's like 88 dude she doesn't know what
the [ __ ] going down
it's called Stevo's hot sauce for your
butthole and if you go on Amazon and
type in Stevo's hot sauce for your
butthole and Order yourself a bottle
you'd be really helping me because right
now we're at ranked number 30 on all of
Amazon and if you buy a bottle we might
go up the ladder and that would mean a
lot so please get on Amazon and buy
Stevo's hot sauce for your butthole yeah
yeah dude